a lot of people know i'm a shoe guy they
want to see my shoes sometimes i put a
glimpse of it like on my instagram story
or my patreon or something like that
so here is my closet tour
or i guess to put it better here is my
shoe tour
[Music]
okay the tried and true shoe to me is
the
jordan one mid and uh
these are these are them these are
jordan ones these are all the jordan
ones i think i got
sometimes people send me shoes like they
sent me these i don't remember who it
was it wasn't nike it was a shoe
a shoe guy because um
i don't remember who sent me these but
these uh and i don't even know what
they're called zoom
but they're iridescent i haven't worn
them yet but they're pretty cool you
know
um and then i got sent these these ones
i bought
which i bought them when they first came
out and now they're really hard to get
the no photos not for resale
and i love those um but these are my
favorite
the union ones um same with these i got
them when they first came out i had no
idea really what i was doing and then i
got them and then they
now they're really hard to get but my
favorite is this
and this the shattered backboard ones i
don't wear these too much because orange
doesn't really like unless i'm wearing
all black
which i am now but um
i'll wear these um these are my favorite
jordans
i think ever probably these or
these i love the lance mountains they're
supposed to chip
like the more you wear them they wear
and there's color under it
and i haven't i mean i've worn them a
lot honestly and it takes a long time
but
i haven't worn them maybe in a year or
so
and i believe they're different colors
like this one's red and this one's blue
yeah um and they've just done like
no like there's a little wear there it
just took too long i wanted it i wanted
it to do but i didn't want to be one of
those guys that did it on organically or
inorganically
that were they like sometimes they chip
it off i don't like that
i just got rid of a lot of shoes
because i don't wear many of these like
even a lot of these i haven't worn
these purple jordan ones are the ones i
wore for no
pain um my special uh on netflix
and i got them to wear them
on that and um
yeah so they're kind of they're special
to me man um
i really like these shoes i don't know
if i've worn them since because they
kind of
have become the shoes that i've worn
there and
in a way they like i like that memory
um i got the 11s here these are the 11s
i have
sometimes i mess up the numbers don't
like kill me dude i'm like a sneaker
dude but like i don't know all the
um and i think that these are the space
jam ones i can't remember
the space jam 11s wow i'm so 41.
40 these are like the people like make
fun of mids now
and i still think that they're the best
man and these are the most slept on
for for me these are the most slept on
the david letterman jordan ones
i love these and you can get them for
price and for retail and i don't know
why people
didn't jump on these these are my my
number one slept on jordan ones i'm sure
people will make fun of me for that but
whatever man
they're so ill dude these i got from
flight club i think these are the jordan
timberlake i don't remember i saw jordan
timberlake where
i'm an idiot they say something on there
stress is cruel
fame is a lie okay sure
you know what i mean there's no reason
to get pretentious with shoes
oh these are though because let
me tell you okay for the sneaker heads
out there
laces you can't redo them they don't
have one of those things on it
so you can't get them even through
one thing so they come like this and i
like to lace them up dude
because you never know when you need to
go to work or run or something
and i'm not going to be one of those
guys who's just unlaced
and uh oh here come the bad guys and
then i got a jet and my shoes are
falling off it happened to my friend i
seen it happen to my friend and he
and he got um he got caught nothing
really happened to him but
um i don't wear them because of these
because i don't like the tongue to be
all fat out you ever see those guys with
the really high
sometimes the guys with a really high
tops and then the tongues comes out and
the jeans tuck underneath it
i don't like that to me that's like so
2006.
and do you know about me dude it's 2021
but i live in the future i'm like 2030
i'm like 2032 2033.
so then let's come over here come over
here these are
my dunks which i don't like high dunks
on nikes i just they look too big and
too
silly and to me they're just not jordan
ones they're like a little bit look like
jordan ones but they're just not jordan
ones
and i know like people will hate me for
that but i just don't care about dunks
that are high
i love low dunks and i've got skinny
legs
so they look a little bit like when i
wear these olives on toothpicks but
i still don't it doesn't i still wear
them and i love them i wear them with
shorts i wear them with pants
um yeah these are the off-white uh air
maxes
some of my favorite off-whites and then
i have the off-white other off-white
um dunks that these are probably my two
favorite ones i know they're coming out
with like 90 of them soon uh
or something like that i can't remember
how many maybe you're like oh and then i
just got these are the newest edition
because i didn't have green shoes and i
love green shoes i like green on two
things
shoes and cars and i don't like the
color green any other time
that's just how i roll dude i don't even
watch the lord of the rings because
there's like so many sprawling forests
and
fields and and i won't watch it and
that's the truth
new jordans that i like are these i wore
them all the time i call them kind of
warm too much
and i don't really wear them all that
much anymore but i like these
what are they called the air co i don't
know
but i like them for the fact that you
can wear them every day
without trying to like be like making a
hey i'm wearing these shoes check out my
cool shoes like the dunks
and some of the jordans that i have
they're kind of understated but uh
i wore them too much in a row one time
when i was in high school i would go and
i would get the number whatever it was
but it was the chicken sandwich
and i loved it so much i ate it every
day and then one day i was just like i
would never eat one of those again
because it makes me want to throw up
so basically that's this version of
these shoes but i love them like i love
that chicken sandwich i guess i don't
like it but i don't like it anymore
but um i might wear these today actually
the undefeated kobe's
i love these these are probably the only
kobe show
hi calvin hey buddy you want to come see
daddy's shoes you take them out and you
throw them around all the time
but these are probably the the coolest i
like these kobe's i don't really love
kobe shoes
rest in peace hey buddy come here you
can come over here come here
you want to pull them out like you
always do look here he goes look
there you go you like those the carolina
are those are carolina
these are the carolina blues i don't
know they're kind of the same to me
these are
air force one highs i don't ever wear
them but i just love the color
hey you got them you like this one same
color kind of well a little different
a guy made me these they're pretty cool
the zipper thing you can take off i
meant to take it off because i don't
want to use the zipper thing
which one which one you like oh you see
the fuzzy in the air
these i love because of the colors the
blazer off-white
halloween i think they're called and so
i really like these these are kind of
where i put the off-whites
i meant to put the dunks over here with
these i don't like how
sometimes i get you know sometimes
christians like you lift your shoes out
and she puts them anywhere
and i'm like baby the off whites go here
there's one lebron shoe i like
sorry lebron but it's the one that he
did with uh john is it john elliott
yeah john elliott these are my favorite
lebrons and they're a collaboration with
john elliott
these white ones sometimes the white
shoes like this with the with the
see-through
they get yellow um so these got a little
yellow but i also because i love them
got the black ones
and the gold ones there's pink ones too
and i was like i'm all in and then i
realized that they were for women
not that i wouldn't wear women shoes but
i didn't feel like getting a size 45 in
women's shoes
a lot of people hate these shoes but
these are the cloth the
yeah the jordan cloth 14s like these and
i like the ferrari 14s
and uh a few other ones but i like
jordan 14s man and
a lot of people don't i don't remember
what number this is tell me in the
comments i forget what these are but i
like these uh oh they made
the new york uh the la and i think
chicago
these here are ones that netflix got me
they gave me these two they kind of came
together i think they come together oh
oh these um these travis scotts are my
are probably i really want the travis
scott ones but these ones
are cool too i should have got those
ones man i had the chance and i didn't
and now they're about
two thousand dollars the jordan
5 toro and then
i think these are called the what the
my dad got me these i haven't worn
them yet don't tell them
but um he got me these for my birthday
which is really cute because he knows i
like shoes
um the cement let's see
oh so all right these are just my these
are my dad's shoes my dad wore these
shoes when i was a kid
and i love these shoes they're the 180s
nike
air 180s and i wear them i wore them
because my dad wore them
when he when when i was young i wore
them when calvin was born
in the hospital which is really cute no
matter what you say and then
i wear them now to work out and stuff
really the ones that are good that are
for working out are these they're kind
of
hiking shoes and trail shoes i forget
what they're called but my buddy got him
scarpa
and i use i use them when i work out a
lot because they're a lot more flat
so shout out to skarpa for keeping it
real like that with the working out
shoes and trail shoes
sakai's i'm a big fan of nike sakai's
i have the white ones i've got these
which are
i don't know what they're called like
the black one and i have one more
somewhere see they're not in order other
work i choose that i have that i like
working out but the soles are gone i
gotta get new ones
reeboks i have very few reeboks but some
of them are banging like the traditional
classic shits
i got these i wore these which ones did
i wear i wore these blue ones
and they're kind of the same but i wore
these blue ones on the netflix thing i
did
comedians of the world my episode of
that which is on comedians of the world
um and then i have these ones too with
green in them these are my air maxes
i have these for my air maxes i guess i
got about five pairs the undefeated i
think
undefeated makes a lot of really good
collabs with nike
they've got these dunks coming out that
i really want to get these are
undefeated as well
are those you that watch my podcast juan
fire got me these
yeah the nike react 10th yeah and then i
have
these which i love which nobody likes
these air maxes are the dude i love
these laces the way they're all like
caterpillar
i love these and nobody likes these
christians christians like these are so
bad but i'm
love them high-end like
i guess gucci like i love with the
wolves
and then the beat and then the flies
and the stars new balance makes some
great
they tried and true always sometimes i
work out in these even they're kind of
when these come out when these came out
again i think it was like a year and a
half ago
i wore them all the time i kind of wore
them out they're a bit grody but the
997s i think
i really like these i used to wear these
in 1998 when i was in
when i was in new york and i was uh in
school and i wore them
every day and people were like
goddamn you got to get other shoes and i
didn't
i didn't i just rocked those i
love these
the 997s uh love the blue love the tan
there's a little secret with these
they're a little big on me and i'm but
it really bumps me out but i still went
on
i believe bodega okay bodega
collaborations are are great i love
bodega collaborations especially with
new balance they made some other cool
ones with saucony but these
are amazing i love these i love how they
like have a little spoiler on the back
and uh like i said i love these
caterpillar laces man
i don't know if what they're called i'm
making up that caterpillar thing but i
love this
they're so they feel all terrain they're
not i mean
you know i wouldn't wear these like in
the in the tundra
so it's not really all terrain but um
love these
are the 997 bodega collaboration
i think that these this collaboration
that bodega did with new balance
i think these are the best new balances
along with these
i love the way this looks i just
love all the colors
the color combinations with it they're
just cool man even on the inside you got
a guy
chilling on the beach that's just too
cool
i'm such a dad i like fear of god
i got some fear of god shoes um three
pair i think
green ones i don't i don't have a clue
what they're called but
love the camo and then these ones
which are cool which i didn't even know
when i got them because i got them
online
um i really like the black and white but
they're like kind of like slip-ons and i
ended
up when i got about the box i was like
oh man i didn't know that but i like
that
because sometimes your boy likes to be
very casual you know i do have that
thing in my head about running away
which you can never run away in these
shoes but you just hop out
and then take like you know
a secret root or something okay now
these here are my yeezys
i'm a sucker i love yeezys and you know
i just i fell for him dude i
fell for the trick kanye made
music but then say what you want about
kanye you know he's so big that he's got
so many haters and also not haters
but like his fashion is so
awesome
except for the red thing he wore on his
face for the dawn to premiere
or listening party so i just kind of buy
them when they come out sometimes
and uh like i got a lot of these um
these style the 350s and i this is what
i hate about the closet
i can't fit three pair of 350s together
because they're too
thick it's two or two wide so i gotta
end up putting two
in and then another style which bothers
me dude
it bothers me love these
um 500 i can't even remember jesus
christ
bro when the when the when the um when
the stress is on
i don't i forget what they're called but
they're i think that the 500s and i have
a lot of these 350s like these are the
second version of the 350s um
these all came these all came which a
few of them came out together and i
i got the three of them the taillights
i think they were this oh and i think
this i think these three all came out on
the same day
and i just got three of them these are
probably
my favorites and i don't
i don't wear them because they're purple
and i think i've worn them once
gotta get on that these are the version
the first versions of the yeezys
i think they're the oxford tan ones and
uh
these are great they're very comfortable
the thing about the 350s
the first versions of the 350s and the
350s is that they're too comfortable
like i can't wear them at night like i
feel like they're daytime
shoes is anybody with me on that i don't
know
like these zebra ones i couldn't wear at
night they're too
contrasty and too they're too
comfortable to wear at night it feels
like i'm wearing a slipper so i wear
them in the daytime to like go get
coffee and all that
love these love that
i got some yeezy boots up here which i
don't really ever wear
just because i'm not really a boot guy
but i do really like the design of them
and these are my favorite but like i
just i just can't wear these
[Music]
season five if i was gonna pick my
my two favorite shoes of all time it
would be the jordan ones
if i was like gonna be on location and i
could only bring two pair
i would bring jordan ones i don't know
which ones i would bring but i would
bring jordan ones
and i would bring my favorite the wave
runners
i got two pair these ones i wear all the
time and they're dirty and i was gonna
wear them until they just broke
and then i've got another pair here that
i'm gonna wear when i like
either shoot something or gotta dress up
and like seem like i know what i seem
like i know about shoes or something but
these are my
favorite yeah these are my favorite
one and two um
jordan one and the wave runners
are my favorite two favorite shoes let
it be known that's it
i think when kanye made these he just
killed it they're just
the right amount of do i like these or
not that they keeps me guessing and i
just love wearing them and they're very
comfortable
there's another kanye shoe that i love
and i
am not this kind of guy who likes these
kinds of shoes
but i put them on and it was over okay
the slides i have one pair of the kanye
slides
and now i'm a slide guy okay so
there's a lot of dust on these but these
are the ones dude
i don't wear slides because they fall
off you gotta
keep your toe up when you take a step so
it doesn't they don't fly off
you don't have to do that with these you
don't have to do that with these
these are the best slides ever i love
these slides and i'm going to get more
so that is um those are all my shoes
i probably had i just got rid of i would
say
i mean this is more these are more shoes
than i need
um but i would say
i probably i had 50 pair that i got rid
of that i gave to friends
and i donated um because i just don't
wear them anymore
and it's annoying to have these shoes
and not wear them and have somebody
and have people out there that would
like them and enjoy them like uh
that i um that they're wearing them
somewhere out in the world now
which is which is wild you don't know
this maybe but you have crystallized
shoes
and uh maybe you
hate my maybe you don't think i'm
funny at all but you're wearing my shoes
so in a way
life has its surprises man and you have
no idea but some
tall drink of water out there with size
13 just walking around
in my uh but by the way that i wore one
time because i never liked them
in my like adidas uh what are they
called the adidas um
what were those socks well i got so many
of the when they came out the adidas
ultra boosts and i just don't wear them
anymore and i donated them and there's
some people out there with the
size 13 adidas ultra boost that doesn't
like my comedy that's still in my shoes
that's hilarious
so that's it that's my closet that's my
shoe tour really hey buddy and he wants
to show you his shoes look you got your
mickey shoes
right here your mickey shoes you like
those
and look at the stunting on them dude
with the jordan ones
your dad has son huh yeah
shoe look at that do you even know how
cool those are look at the socks
like he's a chick in the 80s with the
high puffy socks that's my closet
tour thanks for watching and then uh
like and subscribe for more videos like
this
[Music]
thanks